foreign
[Music]
guys here we are back once again doing
another book review my little tomes of
Terror show so AJ Wills um is a English
writer and I guess like looking at his
bio as he worked as a journalist for
like 10 years or something like that and
then ended up becoming a full-time
novelist in 2021 which I guess was his
longtime dream or whatever so you know
that's congratulations that's like
pretty awesome
um so I had actually heard his name
before
and because of that I guess I started to
think well maybe I had read some of his
stuff because you guys know if you've
like watched some of my book reviews
it's like sometimes I'll like start
reading a book and being like wait a
minute this like author's name sounds
kind of familiar and then I'm like oh
duh like I've already read something of
theirs before because I read a lot and I
kind of forget so I thought that I had
read some of his work before because I
just had heard his name but when I
looked at some of his other novels um
none of them really rang a bell so I was
like okay I guess not maybe I just heard
somebody talking about him like on one
of the book review things that I watch
or whatever
but uh as it turned out his latest novel
which is called the warning
and it just came out in April of 2023
and it came up in my Kindle unlimited
recommendations and I was kind of like
in the mood for a good thriller you know
what I mean because I hadn't read one in
a while so I decided I was gonna go
ahead and pull the trigger on it
um now it seems as though all of Will's
novels as far as I could determine are
uh just Thrillers like this and with
kind of like a lot of twists and turns
and this one is along those lines as
well I believe he's also married to a
woman that also writes Thrillers so
that's kind of cool
um and this book the warning it's like I
had a couple like tiny small like
niggling issues with it but overall this
was like a pretty great
um very gripping book it was like a page
Turner for sure like I said I usually
read them like on my phone like over my
lunch hour and stuff and I kept like
wanting to get back to it you know what
I mean so that's really good like I kept
I read it like really really quick you
know what I mean because I kept wanting
to go back to it and see what was going
to happen
so the story of the warning it's sold in
the third person but from just the sole
perspective of this woman named Megan I
think in the British version her name is
Zoe but I just I thought I saw that and
I was like okay whatever
so about 10 months prior to the events
of the novel
um the house that belonged to her and
her husband Justin burned down I mean it
didn't completely burn down but it was
like you know pretty much essentially
destroyed by fire like I think it's
still there but it's all like you know
up and everything
now this fire killed the couple's two
young Sons whose names were Felix and
Sebastian now the fire was ruled
accidental
but it apparently happened after Megan
drank too much one evening took a
sedative on top of that and then
evidently like went into the other room
and like turned on a faulty heater like
they kind of knew that it wasn't working
all that good and turned it on and then
that ended up and then she fell asleep
and that ended up setting the curtains
on fire and then the Flames kind of
spread to the rest of the house like up
into the kid's room and they died of
smoke inhalation
so not surprisingly
because of this uh Megan is just like
inconsolable so not only has she lost
obviously the two most precious things
in the world to her her two children but
she also blames herself for killing her
kids you know what I mean which is
her up all all kind of ways and
as if that isn't bad enough like the
fire was kind of like a big deal like in
the media so it was like in all the
papers and on TV and everything like
that so now the public is largely
blaming her too like you fell asleep and
you killed your babies and it's like
she's been getting death threats and
like all this other kind of so you
know not helping her mental state and
also you know obviously as would happen
any kind of tragedy like this um her
marriage to Justin is kind of strained
but it does seem as though at least at
first
um that maybe their shared grief is kind
of like bringing them closer together
rather than driving them further apart
now Megan obviously suspects that Justin
you know even if subconsciously like
blames her carelessness for the boy's
deaths but he does stay with her and he
tries to be you know he tries to step up
he tries to be like really supportive
and perfect for her and like be there
for her and like give her space to heal
and all this other kind of stuff and
Megan says many times like at the
beginning of the story that she doesn't
really know what she would have done we
without him like she needs him being
there like as her support system
now because the couple's house was like
I said it didn't burn down completely
but it was severely damaged by the fire
obviously the pair have been staying in
rental properties
um until they can kind of get an
assessment on whether their house is
going to be able to be like salvaged and
rebuilt and how long that's going to
take like if you know that is indeed the
case
so
um Justin ends up telling Megan that
he's like you know there's this remote
Cottage in Cornwall that I used to stay
in over the Summers with my family when
I was growing up and it became available
for long-term rent
and Justin has so many pleasant memories
of spending his Summers there that he
decides he's going to rent this house
Without Really Consulting Megan about it
first
um he's kind of like figuring that well
you know getting away from the city and
getting away from all the media scrutiny
and everything like that will be good
for us and he's like plus I have so many
good memories at this place and I want
to share that with you or whatever even
though she's not super jazzed about the
idea so the cottage is located kind of
on this isolated like a big estate
called tree lore trilor something like
that
um and this is owned by this kind of
like aristocratic family who are away in
France most of the year like it's a
whole like old school like British
aristocracy kind of deal where they have
like the manor house and there's all
this like huge property and everything
now when Megan and Justin first get
there
Megan is um let's call it less than
enthusiastic like about this place like
the house is kind of like miles from any
civilization really
um you know it's kind of dated it hasn't
really been kept up because no one's
really been staying in it so it's kind
of it's not trashed but you know what I
mean it's kind of like shabby you know
um and Justin is kind of like
disappointed that Megan is not really
doesn't really seem to like it like
isn't really into it and he's so he kind
of tries to cajole her into seeing how
awesome it is like seeing the potential
and everything and she kind of like
tries to pretend that she's excited as
he is because she doesn't want to let
him down there's that kind of thing
going on too where she just like wants
to please him all the time but um he
isn't really fooled and kind of knows
that she's not really into the idea and
then uh to make matters worse when they
first get there like and Megan this is
the first time that she's seeing the
place when they go to explore the
upstairs they discover that someone has
been squatting in this house like they
go up in one of the bedrooms they find
like a sleeping bag and like food
wrappers and like drink things and like
it kind of smells funky in there like
somebody's been likes you know it smells
like sweaty like somebody's been up and
they're like staying
um now it doesn't look like anyone has
broken in like none of the locks are
broken and the windows are broken or
anything like that so however this
person got in they didn't break in and
it doesn't look like anything's been
taken or messed up or destroyed or
anything like that but it just looks
like somebody's been staying in there
so Megan again not surprisingly is super
like not comfortable like staying in
this house until everything is like
checked and cleared out and everything
she's like you know what if this
squatter like decides to come back and
I'm here by myself it's like it's not
like I said very understandable you
don't really want because it's obvious
that someone has recently been staying
in there and she's like yeah they could
be coming back like any time and I don't
really like that idea so she basically
insists she's like okay well we're gonna
go stay in a hotel tonight
while uh the rental agent whose name is
Harriet she gets the property overseer
like the guy that you know looks after
the grounds in the house and everything
his name is Colin he's this grizzled old
fart
um and he's gonna come in and like clean
everything out and make the place
livable make sure all the locks are
still working and all of that jazz
now not too long after moving into this
house
Justin has some kind of like emergency
at work and this necessitates him being
gone for several days now Megan is just
beside herself um and she's actually
like pretty resentful about this because
Justin had actually promised like this
was his idea and he had actually
promised I'm gonna take the whole week
off work and I'm gonna stay with you
when we're gonna do like a couple time
and like reconnect and you know and I
want you to ease you into this because
he's like because I know it's a big
change and it's isolated and everything
like that and she's still obviously it's
only been 10 months since her boys died
so she's still not you know she's still
very fragile and everything and she kind
of needed him to lean on and he suddenly
oh gotta go you know and he's just like
gone all the time and she's just like
stuck out here in this house that she
doesn't even really like like by herself
so there's that whole thing going on and
there's also the issue of this possibly
dangerous squatter who may or may not be
back at any time so you know and she
doesn't have any friends around or
anything like that
um now the only Lifeline that she really
has is Harriet the rental agent who is
actually like pretty sympathetic and
actually does befriend her so she does
have that um you know like she gives her
phone number and she comes by like to
check on her and everything like that
um but other than that she's kind of a
little bit I don't know like at sixes
and sevens I guess she's just doesn't
really know what to do with herself and
then one day when Megan is in this
isolated creepy house like by herself
she hears a sound that resembles like an
old cell phone ringing like somewhere in
the cottage so she searches like
furiously all over the place like
looking for where this noise is coming
from and she ends up finding this old
like Nokia phone
um that still has a charge and it's
stashed up in the attic Loft
so she's like well did this belong to
the squatter or to a former tenant
because like I said this was like a
Summer Rental Cottage obviously
whoever's phone it is it's been they've
been here recently because this still
has a charge and you know the phone
doesn't keep a charge that long
so she's kind of like starts looking at
the phone like looking at the messages
and stuff like to see if she can figure
out whose phone this is so she can
possibly return it or figure out what's
going on but instead she finds a text in
there that basically says don't trust
your husband
now at first obviously as you would she
thinks well this message is directed at
someone else right she's like this isn't
my phone this isn't even really my house
um so you know obviously this is to
somebody else but as the texts still
keep coming in uh one of them they
eventually start referring to Justin by
name so she's kind of at this point
forced to contend with the possibility
that someone is either legitimately
trying to warn her about something or is
trying to like plant ideas in her head
for some nefarious purpose that we don't
know what it is yet now previous to this
uh Megan had really never had any reason
to fear her husband she um didn't trust
him completely because he had like
cheated on her at one point like um a
long time passed but the messages are
really starting to get to her and like
give her pause you know what I mean
because it's more than one like they
keep coming in another thing that's kind
of causing her to doubt herself is is
that um everybody else on the estate
like Colin the overseer guy and like the
aristocratic family who owns the estate
like when they eventually come back uh
to the house they kind of have
seemingly
um hostile reactions to Justin uh
returning because remember he spent
Summers there like as a as a teenager
and so they all know him they all like
remember him and uh so obviously they
don't remember him fondly though
um but when Megan tries to figure out
like what it is that you know it's like
what's the matter like why you know why
do you guys like not like him or why do
you talk about him like that this like
some of them don't really want to get
into it you know what I mean so and the
thing about it too is that Justin really
only told her about all the happy times
that he had at this place like as a
teenager so she's like what exactly is
going on here because like there's some
that he's probably not telling me
so as The Story Goes On um you know the
mystery starts getting deeper and deeper
now I and you know I will say right here
this isn't really a spoiler um but you
know potential readers if you want to go
into this completely blind you may want
to like skip ahead some but like I said
this is necessarily a spoiler because
it's a thriller so you kind of know how
it's gonna go
um but it is fairly obvious uh to the
reader that Justin is hiding something
so like for a long time you're not
entirely sure what that is though
now one thing that I will say one
because remember I said that I had like
a couple of small issues with it uh one
of the uh one of these issues that I
talked about earlier was that because
you're seeing everything from Megan's
point of view it's pretty clear
immediately
um that Megan is constantly making
excuses for Justin's Behavior which is
very very controlling like he's
constantly gaslighting her he's
constantly
um you know thinking that he knows
what's best for her when she is maybe
like not she's like yeah I don't think
that's how but you know if that's what
you think you know what I mean she's
kind of like going along with it
um and this is like a was a little bit
like infuriating because it's you know
it's very plain that Justin is like a
big dick he's a dick but she just kind
of like refuses to see it she's always
kind of like making excuses for him
because like I said this is all this is
all from her point of view so the things
that she's thinking it's like really
infuriating because you're like he's
just clearly a jerk I don't know why you
can't see it
um I mean this isn't really okay like I
call it an issue I guess it's not really
an issue per se because
the way that her character is and
a woman in a relationship like this
um this is likely how they would think
and behave in real life so it's not like
inaccurate I'm just saying that but um
sometimes like you're when you're
reading it though like you just kind of
want to slap her and like tell her to
get a clue you know already
because you know it's like I said he's
so just obviously like a douchebag
um also I have to say like she kind of
makes some very very dumb decisions like
as the story progresses but again this
is not surprising like given how long
that she's been kind of like steadily
undermined by this dude like over the I
think they've been in a relationship for
like 12 years or something like that so
it's kind of like really kind of like
chipped away at her self-esteem and
she's in a very vulnerable place right
now because of the death of her kids and
everything like that
um so it is kind of frustrating to read
about sometimes though and I'm gonna say
like it even though it's like
uncharitable and you can unders but you
can understand like where she's coming
from but I did still keep wishing that
she would kind of like hurry up and grow
a spine and like you know wake up and
smell the coffee like pretty much and
like see what what her husband was
really like gonna say though that the
story isn't quite as straightforward as
it seems uh you know at first impression
uh and so AJ Wills like the author he
does throw in some curveballs that I
didn't necessarily see coming I mean I
did get in the ballpark but I didn't
know exactly how it was gonna go so
there's that the only other very small
issues that I had with the book uh some
of the peripheral characters that I
thought were going to like play into the
story more and they didn't really
um and I'm gonna say like the slightly
unbelievable or I don't know about
unbelievable but kind of like over the
top a little bit you know the the kind
of like plot stuff that was going on at
the end but the thing about it is like
I'm not gonna like ding this book
specifically for that because Thrillers
that's kind of their whole thing it's
like they usually have these crazy
twists or like these outlandish kind of
like plot things that happen like in the
third act or whatever so I kind of feel
like that's just a thing that happens in
the genre and this one is actually like
Fair really restrained I guess like
compared to some other stuff that I've
read so I'm not going to complain about
that too much
um but overall I did actually have a
really great time with this book
um it and it hooked me right away
um you know I got right into the story
and I really kind of found myself like
unable to put it down like I kept
wanting to go back to it and stuff like
that it's not super long it's about 400
Pages give or take
um and I read it like really really
quickly like just over my lunch hours
because I kept wanting to go back to it
um so even though I did find the
character of Megan a little bit pitiful
and like a little bit maddening at times
um because you just kind of wanted her
to wake up like I said
um but I still was reading for her even
while I was reading it and I was just
like wishing that I could kind of like
step through the pages and just like
kick her up the ass and like get her ass
moving you know what I mean so it was
that kind of thing but like I said I
guess I guess that's good because that
was like a realistic character like
given the situation that she was in so
I'm gonna say like if you're in the mood
for just like a good classic style like
domestic Thriller uh you know that has
kind of like your requisite interesting
twists and turns and stuff like that
um I found this a very quick very
compelling read like it's nothing you
haven't read before like it's not
Reinventing the wheel you know like I
usually say but you know and it had a
couple small negatives in the sense that
I don't know how some people might
respond to her character some people
might find her character like too
frustrating
uh you know to want to follow or you
know uh not really sympathize with but I
actually did sympathize with her even
though I wanted to smack her like
sometimes
um but it is a very entertaining and
very engrossing story and if it sounds
like your jam then I would definitely
recommend it like I thought it was
really good so that will do it for this
tomes of Terror hope you guys enjoyed it
please remember to like share subscribe
and all of that good stuff and I'll see
you guys again on the next one bye